our launch america coverage is counting
down to wednesday's historic
liftoff of a spacex rocket it will carry
astronauts into space
from u.s soil for the first time since
2011
nasa astronauts bob bankin and doug
hurley
arrived at the kennedy space center last
week and they will launch aboard
spacex's crew dragon capsule when they
reach the international space station
they'll meet astronaut chris cassidy who
has been in command of the iss since
last month
we spoke with cassidy about his role in
this mission
all right commander chris cassidy we're
on the brink of a major milestone
in space flight in the history of space
flight up until right now only countries
have put a capsule
into orbit and then brought it back and
now we could have
a company do it spacex with two of your
colleagues two american astronauts on
board
how big of a deal is this mission oh
it's a gigantic deal
i mean we retired the shuttle uh for
very sound reasons when that decision
was made with aims to move towards the
future and now the future is here
one of the questions when nasa teamed up
with commercial companies to
try to do something like this was how
will the culture of safety at nasa
match up with the corporate ambition of
a company
like spacex so how confident are you
that as your friends
get into that capsule they're going to
arrive there safely
oh i'm very confident they're smart
engineers at nasa they're smart
engineers at spacex
all with motivation to do the same thing
and that's fly missions effectively and
safely i think it's been healthy for
both
the commercial guys who faster faster
and cheaper
and nasa with a more uh decades based of
safety culture
i think it's been healthy for the growth
of both organizations
are you worried about coronavirus as
these additional astronauts arrive
well certainly we're worried about it
we've we have confidence
that the testing in the program and the
regime that that the medical folks are
are putting bob and doug through and the
protections that they have
will mitigate that as low of a
probability as we can
i was joking around with my colleagues
my crewmates last night and said hey
maybe we should have them
come in through the hatch and and make a
hard left and we'll isolate them here in
the corner for a couple weeks before
we'll
we'll treat them to a meal i was hoping
to give us some perspective
on what it's been like to be up there
knowing that so much sorrow
is going on below with the pandemic tens
of thousands of people
in the u.s alone dying in the weeks that
you've been on this mission
just what's it like with the wonder of
what you're doing and the tragedy of
what's going on below
i have watched news segments and you see
those numbers that i think
everybody's watching and it dawned on me
a week ago that every single one of
those numbers
is a story it's a family it's a life
and that was impactful to me
particularly as i was looking out the
window
thinking about it elon musk the founder
of spacex has said
that he hopes that we as a species
humans will become multi-planetary
we'll be able to get off of this planet
the pandemic certainly puts that in
perspective and i'm curious
do you share that goal or that hope do
you hope that humanity
may throw off the bonds of earth itself
oh absolutely and i think it's
definitely going to happen it's just a
matter of what the time scale is maybe
it's in 100 years but
it's just been a little over 100 years
since the wright brothers flew
and think of where we are now me talking
to you from the space station so that's
quite incredible and i'll end that
thought with when i first became an
astronaut in 2004
john young famous uh astronaut was still
in the office
and i remember him saying single planet
species don't survive
so that has stuck with me all these
years i understand you have
an american flag there left by the last
americans who came from u.s soil
where is it what's the plan for for
passing that flag on
it's around the corner about 40 yards
away from me hanging in the u.s
laboratory
and doug hurley was a member of that
last shuttle flight to bring the flag up
here
doug hurley is also as you know on this
spacex flight and he'll bring that flag
home so he's an integral part
of this capture the flag so to speak so
it's it's had uh quite a bit of space
flight experience this flag has
all right well we wish everybody luck
and i have to say commander cassidy
as i say goodbye as a florida boy who
grew up watching the space shuttle and
the space program it is truly an honor
to talk to you
i enjoyed my time i all the best to you
guys at cbs
cassidy is a class act there this is a
former navy seal this is his third trip
to space he's scheduled to return
on a russian vessel in october but
there's a lot to do
before that i love so much about this
story and about this moment gail
and one of the things that i think is
particularly noteworthy is this is a
program that began under the obama
administration this this public-private
partnership nasa and spacex
and now president trump is going to go
down and see it off so
at a time when there's so much fighting
and dysfunction in government this is a
moment of continuity that i think is
very special
i think we can all agree we want this to
go well regardless of whatever your
political party is but
tony i really like chris cassidy he was
so relaxed and so confident and so
welcoming and warm
i thought he was very special that was a
great interview i love that conversation
i got a nice note from him afterwards as
well he is a class act
all the way and he'll be there waiting
to open the door for his colleagues on
wednesday
all right and uh speaking of wednesday
our launch america
coverage will continue throughout this
week tomorrow we're going to look at
some of the incredible accomplishments
and notable
failures there have been those as well
in spacex's history then on wednesday
afternoon we're going to join norah
o'donnell for complete coverage
of this historic historic launch